foreign
if you guys had to get 34 000 worth of
cocaine oh [ __ ]
across the border or a flight how much
would that be
yeah see like a briefcase size probably
less right 34 yeah that's it that's 34
cave damn Cooks valuable get it across
the border I'm gonna get it across the
border from like well in air while on
air travel only air travel yeah uh
commercial airplane commercial airplane
if you're gonna
if you're gonna smuggle cocaine that's a
pretty small that's like a kilo or two
what are most dogs sniffing yes ass
34 kilos of ass are they sniffing are
they sniffing because twice a couple
times bombs oh only I thought they do
drugs
for drugs because I did a uh that that
uh cruise I did with Jacob and luau yeah
they had dogs sniffing you all over yeah
big old German Shepherd scariest [ __ ]
they're like don't look at a chewed I
have no drugs on me but I know this
German Shepherd mean as [ __ ] like and
he's just sniffing everything we do dude
whenever I see them sniffing between old
ladies legs I'm like
survive
when you go to the airport and you do
this thing what does it show metal it's
x-ray is that metal only so it doesn't
show [ __ ] it doesn't show anything it
just shows like a bump if you have it or
something don't don't please don't touch
me there but if I put it over if I put a
kilo of coke up my butt it won't show up
right oh it's not gonna see through it I
think I don't think so oh yeah yeah you
keister it you keep stress yeah that's
what you do yeah what's up Maria full of
grace
you seen that no I think it's a movie
I think it might be the hot lady from
Spanglish sounds like a church
oh balloons okay John's a balloon I have
an idea but I'm just stealing a
Stevenson I haven't seen that movie oh
okay all right is it her no but she saw
two so and Steven's one of the Steven
Seagal movies he breaks in his wrist no
what he did is or what the villain did
in this movie is they took all the
powder and they soak all t-shirts with
it like white t-shirts and then they
ring and then they dry it and they put
the t-shirts into plastic bags so it
looks like you're just transporting a
bunch of brand new t-shirts when you get
to the location you put all the t-shirts
back in the water and you soak them and
you wring them out and then now you
recollect the coke I don't think who's
getting my Coke out of my deal at the
end is going to be happy with that
process yeah because what happens to the
coke yeah it got soaked in water okay
then go somewhere else for your Coke
[ __ ]
on t-shirt t-shirts and coats okay the
t-shirts are good hey good luck to you
by the way is that what they do though
with the sticker you know how they brush
their bag with the stickers oh yeah
that's to find all like the chemicals my
[ __ ] I was holding the battery that day
and it went off oh yeah it's for bombs
yeah I think it's bomb [ __ ] not Coke
[ __ ] oh okay I don't know Coke you would
think you'd be
like I mean the X-ray your bag I guess
or you put it in a tub of protein powder
right that's what I mean
what if the security was proven make a
[ __ ] Shake right now and down it
it's not mixing very well it's a
prototype
so a Colombian man was detained in
Barcelona after he reportedly tried to
smuggle about 34 Grand worth of cocaine
under his toupee
you know what that's out of a Mr Bean
movie you would never think that guy's
smuggling yeah never this hey this is
this is back comedy yo oh my God you
think he has personal use I have no idea
come on you can't talk [ __ ] you can't
talk [ __ ] if he made it through once
before yeah he got somewhere he's like
it worked last time that's like a kid
playing hide and seek and he's like
still never find them
that can't be cocaine you sound like a
man who's played a lot of shitty hide
and seek
he's had to have gotten away with
smuggling before and then he worked his
way up to that bro but that's that's
good it was like an ounce and then it
just got bigger and his hair got higher
this guy's a legend first of all a
[ __ ] Legend he just pushes imagine
his look on his face with like sorry
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
it's like a green beret
I don't know I wonder how they found it
was the dog like look at it dude he's
got it's like it's like bulging out yeah
it's like floating they kept it
kept it this is an art piece bro this
isn't real talk where was this Barcelona
Barcelona oh my god do they have a big
coke scene out there I think Coke is
everywhere man a Beezer right now so
this is this is the part of the article
that made me laugh too they said um they
caught him the man caught their
attention when he arrived on a flight
from Bogota on June 18th and appeared
nervous
he was just sweating so he [ __ ] it up
with his nervousness he probably could
have got away with it yeah yeah [ __ ] him
do you think they look at Colombian
flights a little different they must
right I mean that's the stereotyping
it's probably true how do you think this
guy walks with that on his head he's
like balanced
he's a sweat like a [ __ ]
yeah it's literally a ball he's
balancing a ball what a weirdo
it's all isolated I would I would rather
just throw that mound in my backpack
yeah yeah or unless humiliating oh you'd
risk it he's yeah for sure then all he
on your [ __ ] head no way dude every
time he sees one of those dogs
you just take a small step you might as
well you might as well just put the
[ __ ] cocaine in your bag and then put
the toupee on top for sure that's a
better idea safer put that on top of
your head that's just my toupee yeah you
have a weight on her shot a wig on top
of his back [ __ ] nothing to see here I
think this is my favorite JK article
we've ever done this is this is a legend
dude that's what I'm saying I told you
guys there's not much info on this one
but this one's [ __ ] god it had to be
his first deal his first drug deal I
mean just visually it's the best thing
ever this guy's Pablo Escobar bro and
the best thing too the police say they
said they're quote there is no limit to
the inventedness of drug drug
traffickers trying to mock control
there's got there's got to be dumb ways
people got coke through as well like
there's gotta be worse [ __ ] ways than
that the folks moving all the damn time
they called this inventive there's no
limit to the invention the nervousness
is what [ __ ] it up not the [ __ ]
Factory they had a giant head
it's it's so ridiculous that it probably
worked yeah exactly like this is
probably worked for him does that guy
look suspicious to you because
he burnt [ __ ] [ __ ] let's investigate
his buddy did this and he was like bro
just put it on top of your head put it
purposely he hung out with three other
dudes that just had [ __ ] high ass
hair yeah camouflage himself yeah how do
you not go hat he's like me and my
colleagues how hot you could for sure
get a cowboy hat Cowboy top hat or what
he should have done was get a buddy
stack on his shoulders long trench coat
hello I'm here to uh get on the airplane
I have elephantitis
I'm very self-conscious don't make me
open my coat
he's like sorry my dick just coughed
[Laughter]
so yeah the man was charged with a
public health violation
and uh we don't know if he's still in
custody or not he's got to be it might
be so ridiculous like just [ __ ] go
that's what you would hope
just don't do it again that guy's the
[ __ ] dude that guy's the best dumb
criminals are the best why don't they
just get a camera crew follow around
guys like this yeah that's the best
reality TV you could ever watch just
seeing him try to get coke through every
day like those criminal videos where
they like try to break into a liquor
store and they fall in through the
ceiling yeah and then now they're trying
to get out but they're locked in yeah I
like the ones where they they tied a a
chain to an ATM machine and then the
entire bottom of their truck gets ripped
off yeah and they're like completely
[ __ ] and stuck now because it's
because they watch the fast and furious
Dom Toretto wrote our name don't they
know it takes two cars idiots should put
a Turbocharger in it
can't do without NOS trying to do the
F-150 get out of here I'm excited for
them to try to use magnets now because
of the newest one had serious magnet
usage the magnet [ __ ] was hilarious
hilarious
I need to watch it I haven't redefined
how magnets work dude it's like the
director just saw magnets being used one
time he's like holy [ __ ] I didn't even
think about this this is gonna be crazy
[Music]